that's the point of no-return
pyrotechnics on set if you guys tase me
against my will I will throw kicks that
is an actual problem something's gonna
happen to me I don't know what I don't
know what's gonna happen man it's
something everyone giving me these
smiles in these wigs I like surprises
but friend said it's unfortunate because
it has to happen cuz I know what that
mean would you give a Ricard said you
needed something from his car you didn't
get anything from his car I did don't
tase me dude if you guys are chasing I
never decided that taser salesman on
Santa Fe are you serious he's showing
some Millennials how that tase if you
guys tase me against my will I will
throw kicks
I think it's admire Clint that you would
think so highly of us to play such a
prank on us to tase you yeah that's a
little of a workday
I trust Jared Jared said it'll be fine
so I it's gonna be okay we're going to
Minnesota next week and we have to ship
our boards there ahead of time and that
time is now we have to take apart the
one wheels and we have to remove the
battery let me put it this way
one wheeling equals freedom meaning
you're not gonna have freedom until
Tuesday of next week I'll just pack up
the boards dude I don't know I have to
take them apart hey I take this as long
we're going to void the warranty
oh it's so much do they cost
so I'm willing to take the risk it's
because we're trying to fly these things
on an airplane and airlines have
regulations against certain battery
sizes so the limit for an airline is 160
watt hours for a battery between a
hundred and 168 depends on the LM the
original one of those had like 135 watt
hours
these guys have 324 watt hours so it's a
big battery that leaves us with a
dilemma we want to be able to ride these
things in Minnesota so what our plan is
and what Nico actually did yesterday he
just removed his battery and he shipped
just the battery there and then checked
the one-wheel into his baggage to fly
with it
more than warning setting up for a
little dry ice to get me and Jared or
trying not to burn ourselves to be
honest probably won't be used but Inigo
wants to do as much practical here as
possible so my instinct tells me it's
gonna end up being videoed let's see how
this hold fingies dry ice is frozen
carbon dioxide so cold that it skips the
stage from solid and goes right into a
gas which is called sublimation and
that's why it looks so cool it's very
very cold it's effective and it's fun
and if we put water in this bottle and
let it start sublimating inside it would
eventually explode which we may or may
not do at the end of the day today
deniability and we may or may not be
doing this Niko's trying to make sure we
get everything as it's written on the
page right now but everyone's also
trying to get their two cents and them
on how to be better and changed so it's
a pushing and getting pull on that I'm
just kind of sitting off to the side cuz
I like lasers maybe that's when Sam is
like get serious it's like you're having
fun still this is like us like thinking
about this inaccuracy utilize utilize
this don't ignore it and then and then
like Oh Beth
no answer that's great that's great but
I need you to focus on the acting your
character which is which is why which is
what the best exactly what you're doing
literally a discussion about character
yeah if you have your suggestions that's
great I would love to hear them but
let's go through the process we don't
follow the process and we end up making
mistakes all right yeah yeah well we're
all filmmakers but everybody has their
contributions that could be hard to
direct until idea is out there and you
can see it and you can adjust it and
everything in their character and they
have thoughts of what makes their
character better what makes it flow as
an actor which is all great but I got to
make sure that we follow a procedure so
I can see this thing that I've written
we can make sure there's no
misunderstandings about the beats have
had on the paper and then make
adjustments I just want to make sure
that we are doing it in the proper order
still haven't ran you just ran it how we
were initially planning on it you get
all the same gags litter the same pacing
the same everything except the character
motivations to do what we're doing makes
way more sense let's just run it let's
just literally run it if you are trying
to stop the laser now before anything
bad is happening it jumps the gun on the
second half of the scene it needs to be
fun and games not stop fun day that's
fine we'll let me pour the water and I
won't say stop the laser I'll say whoa
this is crazy rent because me running
like do it do it do it me running and
causing mischief goes exact opposite of
what I was doing in the beginning yeah
there's a consistent come ideas there
it's the same I understand it's two
characters thank you yes yeah what's a
bride through it but the my thing we
think about it so much over analyzing it
you got to feel it out we shouldn't be
having this conversation by describing
how we think it should go Ren Clint
myself we should play this out and if it
feels right or feels like something's
working well no and if it feels like
this bond oh let's just do it though
standing around talking about it isn't
the best choice I'm going to try it your
way to see how it is but Sam I need your
promise if we try it and I don't go with
it they've still willingly admit to what
I want to do yes but like let let us
experiment a little bit here
now I got you guys going for
interrupting your moment seems like a
bet that functions but alright slow it
down guys give me one more version like
you guys are doing ready
I have a feeling that you don't really
you're not respecting this laser I think
we should just put it out before it gets
out of hand I think that's probably the
best idea
I appreciate this new director you guys
want to take it take it back what's on
page let's do it guys
all right here can someone make that
yellow I'm Tom Cruise thing into a
ringtone and put it on our subreddit
that'd be great thank you
why are we going to Minnesota well first
and foremost we're gonna do be doing
some scouting and in addition to that
being that Sam Niko and myself are all
from there we wanted to show the town
after the rest of the guys and have them
check out the sights and sounds they're
really really well engineered they're
built like tanks and they do not like us
making videos about taking them apart
they've explicitly told me that but you
know what I bought this thing at full
price I can do what I want to with it I
put some extra hot glue in here too now
to remove the bumper screw
this is this is great because this
serves on top of a bumper that serves
its protection against the bottom of the
board here very cool there's one motor
wire we got to make sure to keep track
of all those screws are taken out okay
there's one there
actually kind of a hard part here trying
to remove this it's just like for real
now it's like taking a part in an iPhone
in terms of how many parts there are and
how difficult it would be to take part
of my but it's good luck getting an
iPhone back together in the same way
I've done it I've done that I've taken
apart an entire iPhone and I put it back
together and it still works really
Jenna dropped her phone and cracked the
screen so we just bought a replacement
screen and I took it apart place it it
wasn't hard did you use a microscope
[Music]
Oh papa I did break it that's okay I
probably want to press it down hard
enough on this well I got the motor out
so now we got to get inside of here
[Music]
pyrotechnics on set all right safety
meeting guys we have explosive devices
keeping some so we just need it we all
gotta watch out it's hot we're going hot
safety meetings yeah bring her to the
day as I predicted a little bit not
playing we're gonna add another VFX shot
to the list some of you may know I know
Nick knows night no because we're both
Eagle Scouts American flags flying up
there you see there's a little solar
panel two solar panels charging a
battery it's gonna go to that lights
probably on a sensor so at night they
don't have to bring the flag down
according to the flag code at night you
bring it down but if you have a light on
it you do not have to do that so they
have a little battery-powered light
shine a light on the American flag all
night there's a flag code that they said
if you don't illuminate it come down it
right US flag code you take it unless
it's made of a material that can
withstand weather you need to take it
down in the storm that one's probably
nylon that's probably fine I have rarely
rains and then at night if it's not
illuminated you got to bring it down
it's not a law people like you know
people own people and their portraits
don't do that people get all of you know
the Patriot people are like oh it's
against the law it's not a lot it's not
long it's flag code it's a sign of
respect
but also you know using the flag for
different purposes is also a speech and
that's protected on the First Amendment
which is more patriotic than just what
you do with the flag so let's light up
the flag and follow the code for the
city awesome what you want to do with
the flag that's on you
ah oh there you are hey guess what this
is one of my favorite segments this is
where I get to use a sponsored bit to
talk about a book that I really enjoyed
come with me let's check it out together
I found that one of my favorite kinds of
stories is when a character repeats time
and I'm not talking about time travel
think of a Groundhog's Day in that movie
Bill Murray wakes up every morning to
discover that he is repeating his
previous day even better check out edge
of tomorrow and I mean lived I repeat
Tom Cruise at his finest in that movie
he repeats his previous day by dying
well what if instead of repeating your
previous day you repeat your entire life
that is the premise of the book that I
want to recommend to you today called
the first 15 lives of Harry August
written by Claire North this book
follows our protagonist Harry August he
is born in World War one grows up leads
a full life but then dies of cancer in
the 1980s except instead of going on to
some sort of after like he's born again
back in the early 1900s but this time he
remembers everything that's right all of
his memories have returned to him from
his previous life and at first he
doesn't take it very well so he ends up
in an insane asylum although the second
time he dies he discovers that there's a
whole community of people who repeat
their lives over and over and over
retaining their memories as they do so
some people are even thousands of years
old as they repeat their lives again and
again but what makes Harry different is
that his memory is perfect north tells
this story in an interesting way because
she actually bounces around between the
various lives that Harry lives in fact
the book opens with him on the deathbed
of his eleventh life and that's when a
young girl who can also repeat her life
shows up to deliver a message at the
world
and and that is something that I find
particularly interesting because they
can send messages through time so this
girl as a child delivers a message to
Harry on his deathbed so that when he
dies and is born again he can do the
same thing to someone else on their
deathbed I really found the philosophy
in this whole book quite fascinating
because it really deals with all the
trials and tribulations and all the
implications of having your life
repeated over and over again there's a
lot of great things that come with that
but also a lot of bad things - I love
how this book explores that and you can
get this book for free when you try
audible for thirty days by going to
slash corridor crew or even texting
corridor crew one word - 500 500 oh yeah
speaking of which audible has what are
called audible originals and they're
just exclusive titles that they fund and
push out on their own and they're pretty
interesting one of them's called the
singularity trap I reckon in that one I
have driven over 13,000 miles in the
last five months if you want to check
this out you can get those books for
free by signing up for a 30-day trial by
going to audible.com/veritasium
[Laughter]
concave gives you extra grip when you're
writing and it also relieves but stress
or the bomb Quito as we call it we got
from crashing read they make great one
wheel accessories
[Applause]
yeah I got the side of that didn't get
the glass
they were good man I am probably doing
this incorrectly yep
you just eat there it is it broke right
there but it is gonna come out now so
oops
two more screws and there underneath the
sticker here that says warranty void if
moved that's the point of no return
that's the point of no return now it
should be able to slide right out
so one of my favorite movies Jared what
movie Spaceballs yeah never seen it I
don't think it's gonna happen because
this screw just spins free I'm gonna
ship it hold the whole thing the whole
thing which could be very expensive yeah
20 pounds there you what makes no sense
to me is if I'm gonna ship this whole
thing they put it in an airplane because
I mean exploding batteries yeah
obviously not yes but there's never been
a single case of a one-wheel battery
exploding even the new XR ones there
yeah we're safe ship this whole thing
that would suck if that's the case well
Clint also think about this whatever the
cost is to ship that to Minnesota uh-huh
you're gonna pay double to get back ya
know for sure yeah that is an actual
problem yeah and which is gonna cost
probably it's not
if you want it they're back Monday
morning not worth it leave it behind but
Clinton what what about us riding
together it's tough
- that's so crazy that one whaling
people's freedom
[Music]
yeah
okay
[Music]
it's not your it's not gonna happen
all hope is lost I thought I could might
as well give you those push-ups now all
right I can't bring my one wheel into
Minnesota my only hope is to ask cliff
tomorrow his because he is a v1 and
they'll actually let you fly with the v1
um luckily cliff is my roommate um so
hopefully he'll be chill with it you
know so I was unable to open up my XR
and take out the battery to bring to
Minnesota so I was wondering if possibly
I'd be able to trade one wheels with you
because I could fly with the v1 with the
battery but I can't with the XR yeah
that's cool that's Jill yeah like if I
break it or if I trust it like there's
anyone I trust with one wheel it's a sub
make another boarding them exactly yeah
it's a ride in Minnesota
Oh for eclipses will so I'll have a
board in this overcharge oh my god dude
thanks a lot man